Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, add free listening, early access to series and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to the rest is history.com and join the club. That is the rest is history.com. This episode is presented by Adobe Express, the quick and easy create-anything app. What does that mean? Well, say you need to make a presentation or a video. video or a social media post or a flyer, maybe even a video. To some, certainly to me, that sounds intimidating. But Tom, with Adobe Express's intuitive features like templates,
感谢收听《历史的 rest》。想要每周获取独家附加节目、无广告收听、剧集抢先体验以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 the rest is history.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 the rest is history.com。本集由 Adobe Express 赞助播出，这是一款简单快捷、能创作任何内容的应用程序。这是什么意思？比如说，你需要制作一个演示文稿或视频。视频、社交媒体帖子或传单，甚至可能是一个视频。对有些人来说，对我而言肯定也是，这听起来让人望而生畏。但是汤姆，有了 Adobe Express 的直观功能，比如模板、
generative AI and real-time collaboration, it has never been easier. Adobe Express. Try it for free. Search Adobe Express in the App Store. At last day came when we left Munich to begin the fulfillment of our duty. For the first time, I saw the Rhine as we rode westward along its quiet waters to defend this, the German stream of streams from the greed of the old enemy. The old watch on the Rhine roared out of the endless transport train into the morning sky, and I felt as though my heart would burst. And then came a damp, cold night in Flanders,
生成式人工智能和实时协作，这一切从未如此简单。Adobe Express。免费试用。在 App Store 中搜索 Adobe Express。最终，我们离开慕尼黑去履行职责的日子来临了。当我骑马向西沿著莱茵河宁静的河水前行时，我第一次见到了莱茵河，去保卫这条德国人的百川之源，免受老敌人的贪婪觊觎。莱茵河畔的旧守望曲从无尽的运输列车中冲向晨空，我感觉自己的心仿佛要裂开一般。随后，佛兰德斯迎来了一个潮湿寒冷的夜晚，
through which we marched in silence. And when the day began to emerge from the mists, suddenly an iron greeting came whizzing at us over our heads. But even before the little cloud had passed, from two hundred throats the first hurrah rose to meet the messenger of death. Then a crackling and a roaring, a singing and a howling began. And with feverish eyes, each one of us was drawn forward faster and faster, until suddenly passed fields and hedges.
我们在寂静中行军。当晨雾中渐渐透出曙光时，突然，一声铁血的问候呼啸著掠过我们的头顶。然而，甚至在那片小小的云团散去之前，两百个喉咙里便爆发出了第一声“乌拉”，迎向死亡的信使。接著，劈啪声、轰鸣声、歌唱声和嗥叫声交织响起。带著狂热的眼神，我们每个人都被不由自主地越拉越快、越拉越快，直到突然掠过田野和树篱。
The fight began, the fight of man against man. And from the distance, the strains of a song reached our ears coming closer and closer, leaping from company to company and just as death plunged a busy hand into our ranks the song reached us too and we passed it along Deutschland, Deutschland, Ober ales Opa Ales in their Welt So I think a very moving passage there
战斗开始了，人与人之间的肉搏战。远处的歌声传入我们的耳中，越来越近，在连队之间回荡，正如死亡将一只忙碌的手伸进我们的行列，歌声也传到了我们这里，我们把它传递下去：德意志，德意志，高于一切，高于世间的一切。所以我觉得那是一段非常感人的选词。
A private in the 16th Bavarian Reserve Regiment remembering his first brush with the enemy in the autumn of 1914, leaving the Rhine behind, coming up to the mud and the slaughter of Flanders. And anyone who finds themselves at this point brushing away a tear from the eye may be stunned to realise that they've been listening to literally the worst man in history because that comes from Mein Kampf by a certain A. Hitler. Dominic, the Hitler here is, I mean, he's relatively speaking, behaving him. himself, isn't he? He's actually articulating there the experiences and the feelings of a lot of
巴伐利亚第16预备步兵团的一名列兵，回忆起他在1914年秋天与敌人的初次交锋，将莱茵河抛在身后，迎向佛兰德斯的泥潭与屠杀。任何在这个时候发现自己正在拭去眼角泪水的人，可能会震惊地意识到，他们听到的简直是历史上最糟糕的人的话，因为这出自某位 A·希特勒的《我的奋斗》。多米尼克，这里的希特勒，我的意思是，相对而言，他表现得很规矩，不是吗？他实际上是在那里表达了许多
Germans and not in a necessarily sinister way. No, you're absolutely right, Tom. He's a young man who is enthused with the camaraderie and the patriotic commitment that so many Germans took into the First World War. And the story he tells there, which is young men advancing into enemy fire, their first time, they're singing the Deutschland lead, the song of the Germans. That The story became, at this point, a central element of German patriotic mythology. So the people who first read Mein Kampf in the middle of the 1920s, they were already very familiar with this story. And the idea became wrapped up with something called the Kindermord, the massacre of
德国人的经历和情感，而且并非出于某种险恶的意图。不，你完全说得对，汤姆。他是一个充满袍泽情谊和爱国热忱的年轻人，许多德国人正是带着这种情谊和热忱投入了第一次世界大战。他在那里讲述的故事，也就是年轻人第一次冲向敌人的炮火，他们唱着《德意志之歌》，即德国人之歌。那个在当时，这个故事成为了德国爱国主义神话的核心要素。因此，那些在20世纪20年代中期首次阅读《我的奋斗》的人，对这个故事已经非常熟悉了。这个概念与所谓的“基德莫德”（Kindermord，即
the innocence, the idea that there's a generation of young men who, at this particular moment in the autumn of 1914, at Ipe, they walked into battle, singing their parents. patriotic hymns. And in some versions of the story, the hymn carries them to victory. In other versions, they are cut down as they walk by a British machine gun fire. They are sacrificing everything for their beloved fatherland. And they're almost walking willingly with a song on their lips, with their patriotic spirit in their hearts, with a kind of Viking spirit almost.
无辜者的屠杀）交织在一起，这种观念认为，有一代年轻人在1914年秋天的那个特定时刻，在伊珀尔，他们唱着父母的爱国赞美歌走向战场。在故事的一些版本中，赞美歌指引他们走向胜利。在另一些版本中，他们在行进时遭到英国机枪火力的扫射而倒下。他们为敬爱的祖国牺牲了一切。他们几乎是踏着歌声、带着心中的爱国精神、几乎怀着一种维京精神，心甘情愿地向前走去。
We've done so many stories on this show about the Vikings kind of going into battle, singing. So at the time, it was a very compelling and seductive idea. Tom, are you seduced by it? Well, I mean, I think of the parallels with the British who were facing the Germans in this stretch of Flanders, but they have very similar stories, don't they? The idea of doomed youth, sacrifice, all of that, framed in different ways. A long way to Tipperary, a song that took off in the final months of 1914. Now, it's all the more powerful, I think, this story, because it's set against the backdrop of one of the most compelling battles of the war, which is the first Battle of Eap, a story full of most extraordinary feats of kind of courage and sacrifice,
我们在节目中做过很多关于维京人唱歌上阵的故事。所以在当时，这是一个非常引人入胜且极具诱惑力的概念。汤姆，你被它吸引了吗？嗯，我的意思是，我想到了那些在佛兰德斯的这一地段面对德国人的英国人之间的相似之处，但他们有非常相似的故事，不是吗？注定的青春、牺牲的理念，所有这些，以不同的方式被构建起来。一首在1914最后几个月风靡的歌曲《一路向西去蒂珀雷里》。现在，我觉得这个故事更加震撼人心，因为它以战争中最扣人心弦的战役之一——第一次伊珀尔战役为背景，这个故事充满了非凡的勇气和牺牲精神，
and we'll be covering some of those today. So we'll come back to the singing a little bit later, but first of all, let's remind ourselves where we got to. The Germans were pushed back from Paris in the Battle of the Marne at the beginning of September. Their commander helmet von Molke had a breakdown and was replaced by the Asurbic, Chile, Prussian War Minister, Eric von Falkenheim. The Germans have fallen back behind the River Ayn. They have started to dig in to carve out the first trench networks.
我们今天将探讨其中的一些内容。所以我们稍后会回到歌唱的话题，但首先，让我们回顾一下我们进展到了哪里。9月初，德国人在马恩河战役中被从巴黎击退。他们的指挥官赫尔穆特·冯·毛奇精神崩溃，被尖酸刻薄的西里西亚普鲁士战争大臣埃里希·冯·法金汉取代。德国人已经退守到埃纳河后方。他们开始挖掘战壕，开辟出最早的战壕网络。
And then there has been the so-called race to the sea, both sides rushing northwards try to get into the last open bit of territory between the trenches and the English Channel. And the goal is break through this stretch of territory before your enemy can dig in because then you can outflank him and strike down into his rear. And by the middle of October, this race is really narrowed to a small expanse of the front, the 20 miles that stretch south from the channel. And there are lots of other battles. So there's a thing called the Battle of Ezer where the Belgians really distinguish themselves.
接着就出现了所谓的“奔向大海”运动，双方都向北急行军，试图占领战壕和英吉利海峡之间最后一块开阔的领土。其目标是在敌人能够构筑防线之前突破这片狭长的区域，因为只有这样，你才能迂回包抄并直捣其后方。到了10月中旬，这场竞赛真正缩小到了前线的一小片区域，即从海峡向南延伸的20英里。还有许多其他的战役。比如被称为“伊瑟战役”的战役，比利时人在其中表现得非常出色。
But today we're going to look at one single point, probably the most celebrated or contested point on the front, which is the town of Epe. So Ebe was mentioned by the Romans. We don't know what it was called, but they mentioned a town in this place. And it's a very old town. It was a big cloth town in the Middle Ages. It's mentioned in the Canterbury Tales, Tom. and it was the third biggest town in Flanders after Ghent and Bruges at its heyday and the symbol of Ipe's importance and its wealth that they have this spectacular gothic
但今天我们将聚焦于一个单一的地点，这可能是前线最著名或争夺最激烈的地点，也就是伊珀尔镇。所以伊珀尔在罗马人的记载中被提及。我们不知道它当时叫什么，但他们提到了这个地方的一个城镇。这是一座非常古老的城镇。在中古世纪，它是一个重要的呢绒城镇。汤姆，它在《坎特伯雷故事集》中被提及，在其全盛时期，它是仅次于根特和布鲁日的佛兰德斯第三大城镇。伊珀尔重要性与财富的象征是他们拥有壮观的哥特式
cloth hall built in the 13th century at the time it was one of the largest commercial buildings in Europe and Ibrch had changed hands many times it had been besieged by the English in 1383 captured by Louis XIV in 1678 captured again by the French and the French Revolutionary Wars in 1794 and this time it's the Germans who want it. Falconheim's plan is that we take Ipr, it's the perfect base from which to strike west to the channel ports of Dunkirk, Calais and Boulogne. And if we can take them, we can cut the supply lines from Britain to the British expeditionary
呢绒会馆，建于13世纪，当时它是欧洲最大的商业建筑之一。伊珀尔曾多次易手，它在1383年被英国人围攻，在1678年被路易十四攻占，在1794年的法国大革命战争中再次被法国人攻占，而这一次，是德国人想要它。法金汉的计划是攻占伊珀尔，这是向西进攻敦刻尔克、加来和滨海布洛涅等海峡港口的完美基地。如果我们能攻占它们，我们就能切断从英国到英国远征军的
force. We can cut the links between Britain and France, and that would be a great step towards winning the war. So he's going to use two armies, the fourth and the sixth German armies, basically to batter their way through. and in their path stand the French 8th Army and the British Expeditionary Force. So the British first march into Ipe on the 14th of October, and this is the 7th Division, and this has been cobbled together from across the British Empire that just landed from England as reinforcements.
补给线。我们可以切断英国和法国之间的联系，这将是赢得战争的伟大一步。因此，他将使用两支军队，即德国第四集团军和第六集团军，基本上是用猛烈炮火杀出一条血路。而挡在他门面前的是法国第八集团军和英国远征军。因此，英国人于10月14日首次挺进伊珀尔，这是第七师，这支部队是由来自大英帝国各地的部队拼凑而成的，他们刚从英国登陆作为增援部队。
So this is the first time they've been to Belgium, these guys. And they think Iep is lovely. One officer writes home, and he says, Eep's rather a nice old town with narrow cobblestone streets and fine buildings and a tremendous lot of priests and nuns. It seems so odd to be fighting in this sort of country. Because, of course, they've come from the empire. They've been fighting overseas.
所以这是这群人第一次来到比利时。他们觉得伊珀尔非常可爱。一位军官在信中写道，伊珀尔是个相当不错的古镇，有着狭窄的鹅卵石街道、精美的建筑以及大量的神父和修女。在这个地方打仗感觉真奇妙。因为当然，他们来自帝国。他们一直在海外作战。
And they have absolutely no sense of the slaughter that lies ahead for them. Now, I'm sorry to report that Sir John French, the Florid commander of the BEF, has not learned his lesson from previous expeditions to Belgium. Oh, that's a shame, because he behaved quite well at the Battle of the Marne, didn't he? He did. But now, unfortunately. So they advance into Flanders and they say, are there going to be some Germans? And he says, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
他们完全没有意识到等待他们的将是怎样的屠杀。现在，我很遗憾地报告，英军远征军（BEF）那位面色红润的指挥官约翰·弗朗西斯爵士并没有从以往远征比利时的经历中吸取教训。哦，那太遗憾了，因为他在马恩河战役中表现得相当不错，不是吗？他确实表现不错。但现在，不幸的是。于是他们挺进佛兰德斯，他们问，会有德国人吗？他说，不，不，不，不，不，不，不。
There'll be no Germans here. I think it's fair to say, Sir John French is the, he'd make an excellent pundit on the rest of politics with his grasp of prognostication. So on the advice of the Rory Stewart of the British Expeditionary Force, the 7th Division head east out of the town. And actually, at first, they say, well, you know, this is actually going to be quite. boring. We're getting fed up of all this waiting and gunner writes. We're anxious to get into action. So out they go into the celebrated Flanders fields. So anybody who's done war poetry or our British listeners surely will have done war poetry when they're at school because it's such a staple of the curriculum. It's all kind of a great moonscape of craters.
这里不会有德国人。我觉得可以公平地说，约翰·弗朗西斯爵士就是……凭借他对预言的掌控，他会成为“历史的其余部分”节目中一位出色的评论员。于是，在英国远征军的罗里·斯图尔特的建议下，第七师向东挺进镇外。事实上，起初他们说，好吧，你知道的，这其实会挺无聊的。我们对这一切等待感到厌烦了，炮手写道。我们渴望投入战斗。于是他们走进了著名的佛兰德斯田野。所以任何写过战争诗歌的人，或者我们的英国听众，在学校里肯定都写过战争诗歌，因为这是课程的核心内容。这完全是一片布满弹坑的月球表面般的景象。
It's kind of Tolkien's Mordor or something. But actually it's not like that at the time at all. Are there lots of poppies? There are poppies. There's loads of poppies. But at this point they're not identified with the war, of course. So there's an Australian writer called Paul Hamm. He wrote a brilliant book about 1914. And he describes it very nicely. He says the bleak rain-drenched land of gentle hills and ridges, fields of tobacco and beetroot interspersed with hedgerows and barns spreading into dreary plains, seasonally strewn with poppies. They go out into this farmland for about five or six miles. On Sunday the 18th, they have their first skirmishes with German patrols, but they still don't really know what lies ahead.
有点像托尔金的魔多之类的地方。但实际上当时根本不是这样的。有很多虞美人花吗？有很多虞美人花。有大量的虞美人花。但在当时，它们当然还没有与战争联系在一起。所以有一位澳大利亚作家叫保罗·哈姆。他写了一本关于1914年的精彩著作。他对此进行了非常生动的描述。他说，这片阴冷、被雨水浸透的土地有着柔和的山丘和山脊、烟草和甜菜田，其间点缀着树篱和谷仓，延伸到沉闷的平原上，季节性地散落着虞美人花。他们走进这片农田大约五到六英里。在18日星期天，他们与德国巡逻队发生了第一次小规模冲突，但他们仍然不知道前方等待着他们的是什么。
and Sir John French says Just keep going The next village is called Paschendale I'm sure that's an absolutely delightful place Definitely never be a battle there Exactly The Hon is running out of men There'll be nobody there
约翰·弗朗西斯爵士说：“继续前进。下一个村庄叫帕斯尚尔。我确信那绝对是一个令人愉快的地方。绝对不会在那里发生战役。”确实如此。霍恩的人快用完了。那里不会有任何人。
And look at all those poppies We'll never need to use them as a symbol For the futility of war Sir John French with his unerring ability To completely mispredict what's happening The Germans are actually advancing With 14 infantry divisions Of course they are
看看那些虞美人花。我们永远不需要把它们用作战争徒劳无功的象征。约翰·弗朗西斯爵士凭着他那绝对不会失手的、完全错误预测事态发展的能力。德国人实际上正在推进，拥有14个步兵师。当然他们有。
The British and French have only seven. The Germans are much fresher. They're fresh troops. They have twice as many guns. They've got ten times as much heavy artillery. So textbooks are John French advice there. On the 19th of October, the Royal Flying Corps head east over the fields. And they come back with bombshell news.
英法联军只有七个师。德国人的状态要好得多。他们是生力军。他们拥有两倍的火炮。他们的重炮数量是英法联军的十倍。教科书般的约翰·弗朗西斯爵士的建议就在那里。10月19日，皇家飞行队向东飞越田野。他们带着重磅炸弹般的消息回来了。
They say, there are actually loads of Germans. And they're only hours away. So the British fall back a little bit. Okay. So this time, John French does actually believe what he's being told. Because previously at Mons, the Air Force had been up and come back, and he's out of nonsense. So to that extent, he is learning. I wonder if there's an element, though, of people no longer listening to Sir John French.
他们说，实际上有大量的德国人。而且他们只有几个小时的路程了。所以英国人稍微撤退了一点。好吧。所以这一次，约翰·弗朗西斯确实相信了别人告诉他的话。因为此前在蒙斯，空军起飞侦察后回来汇报，而他却认为是无稽之谈。从这个角度来看，他在吸取教训。不过，我不知道这其中是否有一种成分，即人们不再听从约翰·弗朗西斯爵士的话了。
I mean, certainly I would, if I was one of his officers, I would be skeptical if he advised me of anything. Anyway, the British foreback, and they established themselves on a ridge just east of Iep. And this is the genesis of something that, you know, if you read books about the First World War, it's always there. It's called the Eepr salient. So salience is basically just a bulge in your line. sort of bulging outwards. Sticks out. It's good news because you can sort of maybe penetrate into the enemy lines. It's also bad news because it means they can surround you on three sides and kind of pour fire into you.
我的意思是，当然我会的，如果我是他的军官之一，如果他给我任何建议，我都会持怀疑态度。不管怎样，英国人撤了回来，他们在伊珀尔东侧的山脊上站稳了脚跟。这就是一个概念的起源，你知道的，如果你阅读关于第一次世界大战的书籍，它总是会出现。它被称为伊珀尔突出部。所以突出部基本上就是你防线上的一个凸起。某种向外凸出的部分。凸出来。这是个好消息，因为你或许可以打入敌人防线内部。这也是个坏消息，因为这意味着他们可以从三个方向包围你，并向你倾泻火力。
This salient is going to play a massive part in the British wartime experience. So the next four years, the British are going to expend 200,000 lives to defend this relatively small patch of land. On the 20th of October, the Germans launched their assault. These great grey columns advancing relentlessly towards the same. The Germans attack very bravely. Actually, these guys are new. They are barely trained reservists. Is Hitler in their ranks? He's not at this point. No, I don't think. He's waiting in reserve.
这个突出部将在英国的战时经历中扮演极其重要的角色。因此，在接下来的四年里，英国人将付出20万人的生命来保卫这一相对较小的土地。10月20日，德国人发起了进攻。这些庞大的灰色纵队无情地向同一方向推进。德国人的进攻非常勇敢。事实上，这些家伙是新兵。他们是几乎没有受过训练的预备役人员。希特勒在他们的行列中吗？他此时不在。不，我想没有。他在后备部队中等待着。
He's waiting in the reserve. But there are very heavy casualties, but the Germans don't break through. Now, meanwhile, the British have been told, dig in, hold the line. None of them have really proper spades. Some of them have kind of trowels and stuff. But a lot of them are actually digging into the clay of the fields. So these aren't chalk. They're clay. They're digging with their bare. hands. And these are the origins of the Eap trenches. The next stage, which is the 21st, loads of reinforcements start to arrive, wave upon way of Germans, but also the first British troops who've come from the Battle of the Aen further to the sort of southwest. And now the struggle
他在预备队里等待着。但伤亡非常惨重，不过德国人并没有突破防线。现在，与此同时，英国人接到命令：就地挖掘，坚守防线。他们中没有一个人有真正的铁锹。有些人有一些类似泥瓦刀之类的工具。但他们中的许多人实际上是在田野的黏土中挖掘。所以这些不是白垩土。它们是黏土。他们用光手挖掘。这些就是伊珀尔战壕的起源。下一个阶段，即21日，大量的增援部队开始到达，一波又一波的德国人，还有从更西南的埃纳河战役赶来的第一批英国军队。现在，争夺
for Eap really begins in earnest. So for the next three weeks, the story is basically the British defending the salient. These are sort of Flemish villages, Zandvojrda, Zonabeke, Langermark, places that if you've ever been to the Western Front you'll probably recognise and the Germans just battering away merciless you're trying to kind of break through it's very confused bloody hand-to-hand fighting there's shells raining down
伊珀尔的战斗真正全面展开了。所以在接下来的三周里，故事基本上就是英国人防守突出部。这些是弗兰德斯的村庄，赞德福尔德、佐纳贝克、兰格马克，如果你去过西线战场，你可能会认出这些地方，而德国人只是无情地狂轰滥炸，试图撕开防线。这是一场非常混乱、血腥的肉搏战，炮弹倾泻而下，
there's machine guns blasting away all the time the Germans time after time come really close to breaking through but always somehow the British were able to push them back Dominic is there the crump of guns I think there is a crump or is it a dull thud I think it's a crump because I think you're obliged by law when describing the Western Front to use the word crump.
机枪不停地扫射，德国人一次又一次地险些突破，但不知为何，英国人总是能够将他们击退。多米尼克，那里有炮弹的“轰隆”声吗？我想有“轰隆”声，还是说是一个沉闷的闷响？我想是“轰隆”声，因为我觉得描述西线战场时，法律规定你必须使用“轰隆”这个词。
It's very much kind of Wilfred Owen kind of territory. Now, all the time, the bodies are piling up, especially, I have to say, the Germans. So the Germans, officers are hurling them forward in these kind of incredibly brave suicidal assault. And actually for the British, we always think of all the British, the victims and all this. But the British, they say it's like being in a shooting gallery. Well, surely like a pheasant shoot of the kind that Franz Ferdinand and the Kaiser and George V that everybody enjoyed. Well, remember, they, because Franz Ferdinand was unfortunately killed,
这非常带有威尔弗雷德·欧文那种领地的色彩。现在，尸体不断堆积，特别是，我必须说，德国人的尸体。因此，德国军官以极其勇敢的自杀式冲锋将他们驱赶向前。事实上，对于英国人来说，我们总是想到英国人、受害者以及所有这些。但英国人说，这就像在一个射击场里。好吧，这肯定就像弗朗茨·斐迪南大帝、德皇和乔治五世都喜欢的那种野鸡猎场一样。好吧，记住，因为弗朗茨·斐迪南不幸被杀，
they missed out on that brilliant weekend that they were going to have together. But for British sportsmen, this is, I mean, you know, shoot a German rather than a pheasant. It must be the attitude. Well, since you do the voice of a well-educated British sportsman, say, well, Tom, perhaps you'd like to read to everybody what Captain Henry Dillon wrote to his parents. I mean, imagine writing this to your parents about a German night attack on the 24th of October. The great grey mass of humanity was charging straight onto us, not 50 yards off. As I fired my rifle, the rest all went off almost simultaneously.
他们错过了那场他们原本打算一起度过的精彩周末。但对于英国运动员来说，这意味着，你知道的，射杀一个德国人总比射杀一只野鸡好。这一定就是这种态度。好吧，既然你模仿了一个受过良好教育的英国运动员的声音，那么，汤姆，也许你愿意向大家朗读一下亨利·狄龙上尉写给他父母的信。我的意思是，想象一下在10月24日写这样一封关于德国夜袭的信给你的父母。庞大的人类灰色洪流正径直向我们冲来，距离不到50码。当我开枪射击时，其余的人几乎同时开火了。
I have never shot so much in such a short time. My right hand is one huge bruise from banging the bolt up and down. The firing died down and out of the darkness, a great moan came, people with their arms and legs off trying to crawl away, others who could not move gasping out their last moments with the cold night wind biting into their broken bodies and the lurid red glare of a farmhouse showing up clumps of grey devils killed by the men on my left further down.
我从未在这么短的时间内开枪射击这么多次。我的右手因为不断上下拉动枪栓而变成了一大块瘀青。射击声渐渐平息，黑暗中传来一声巨大的呻吟，那些手脚被炸飞的人试图爬开，另一些无法动弹的人在冰冷的夜风撕裂他们破碎的身体时喘息着度过最后的时刻，农舍诡异的红色火光映照出一丛丛被我左侧、更远处的人击毙的灰色恶魔。
A weird, awful scene. So a hideous shooting party. A hideous shooting party, and weirdly that he would write to his parents about it. Anyway, different times. Now, for the Germans, it's an indescribable horror. So Max Hastings quotes this bloke from Würtenberg called Paul Hubb. He's been fighting for a village called Gelyuvel, which we'll come back to. And he writes to his wife, and he says,
一幅诡异而可怕的场景。所以这是一场可怕的射击派对。一场可怕的射击派对，奇怪的是他居然会把这件事写信告诉父母。不管怎样，时代不同了。现在，对德国人来说，这是一场无法形容的恐怖。因此，马克斯·黑斯廷斯引用了符腾堡一个叫保罗·胡布的人的话。他一直在为一个叫格卢韦尔的村庄战斗，我们等一下会回到这个地方。他写信给妻子说：
My dear Maria, I've lived through such horror recently, no words can describe it. Every day the fighting gets fiercer and there's still no end in sight. Our blood is flowing in torrents all around me The most gruesome devastation I didn't think war would be like this And there must be a lot of people Who are thinking that by this point Oh yeah
我亲爱的玛丽亚，我最近经历了如此可怕的事情，言语无法形容。每天的战斗都更加激烈，而且仍然看不到尽头。我们的鲜血在我周围如泥石流般流淌。最可怕的毁灭，我没想到战争会是这样的。到这个时候，肯定有很多人
Yeah, those I mean basically everybody at this point says This is definitely not what we signed up for This is a new kind of warfare Machine Gums, shells Mud, rain, Barbedoire This is not the sort of romantic adventure That I had dreamed of as a boy Or anything like that
都在这么想。哦，是的。是的，我的意思是基本上在这个时候每个人都说这绝对不是我们签约时想要的。这是一种新型的战争。机枪、炮弹、泥浆、雨水、铁丝网。这不是我小时候梦想的那种浪漫冒险，或者诸如此类的事情。
On the 30th of October, the German offensive reaches a crescendo. Falcon Heinz now brought in a new army group, new troops, hundreds of heavy guns and howitzers. The Germans now have a two-to-one advantage. The classic sort of Western front scene. The bombardment starts at dawn, an absolute kind of storm of shell fire. Then at 6.30, the German infantry, go in. Slowly but surely, it seems like they're going to break through. They take the chateau-zand-vorder.
10月30日，德国人的攻势达到了高潮。法金汉现在带来了一个新的集团军、新的部队、数百门重炮和榴弹炮。德国人现在拥有二比一的优势。典型的西线战场场景。轰炸从黎明开始，绝对是一场炮火风暴。然后在6点30分，德国步兵发起冲锋。缓慢但坚定的是，他们似乎要突破防线了。他们攻占了赞德福尔德城堡。
They drive back the household cavalry. But, as always, this is the absolute story of the Western Front. Halfway through the day, it looks like they're going to win, and then their offensive falters, they ran out of steam, and somehow the British were able to hold out and push them back. And that night, the German commanders are told, well, you just do it the same again the next day, do it again tomorrow. And one of them says to his colonel, he says, excuse me here, or best, the word battalion has been mentioned.
他们击退了近卫骑兵。但是，就像往常一样，这绝对是西线战场的剧本：到了白天过半时，看起来他们要赢了，然后他们的攻势步履蹒跚，他们精疲力竭，而英国人不知怎么地能够坚守阵地并把他们击退。那天晚上，德国指挥官被告知，好吧，你第二天再来一次，明天再干一次。其中一个人对他的上校说，请原谅，或者最好是提到了营这个词。
We, in the center, no longer have a battalion. The men have been in battle for 48 hours, and they have had no sleep. for three nights. In other words, we're falling apart. And the colonel goes ballistic and he says, do you say impossible? There is no such thing as impossible. We're all soldiers. We must accept the risk of death. And so it is on the 31st of October. It starts all over again. And the military historian J.P. Harris says this is one of the most critical days fighting, not merely of 1914, but of the entire war. Because the British at this point are really on their last legs. A decade or so later, historian of the British Expeditionary Force, famously said they were a thin line of tired,
我们中央部队已经没有一个营了。士兵们已经连续战斗了48小时，而且已经连续三个晚上没有睡觉了。换句话说，我们正在崩溃。上校勃然大怒，说道：“你说不可能？没有不可能这种事。我们都是士兵。我们必须接受死亡的风险。”就这样，10月31日来临了。一切又重新开始了。军事历史学家J·P·哈里斯说，这是最关键的战斗日子之一，不仅是1914年的，而且是整个战争的。因为英国人此时真的已经精疲力竭了。大约十年后，英国远征军的历史学家有一句名言：他们是一支由疲惫、
haggard and unshaven men, unwashed, plastered with mud, many and little more than rags, all that stood between the British Empire and ruin. So again, another relentless barrage. And then in come all these waves of the kind of grey German uniforms. And this time, the epicentre of it is this village called Gelywelt. And there's so many Germans that they're pretty much irresistible. And by about 1230, they have forced pretty much all the British troops to fall back. There's just one unit left, and that's the first South Wales borderers who are defending the chateau at Gellewelt under overwhelming fire.
憔悴、满脸胡子、不洗脸、满身泥浆、许多人衣衫褴褛的人组成的薄薄防线，这是大英帝国和毁灭之间仅存的一切。又是一轮无情的轰炸。然后，所有这些灰色德国制服的浪潮蜂拥而入。这一次，风暴的中心是这个叫格卢韦尔的村庄。德国人实在太多了，他们几乎势不可挡。大约到12点30分，他们迫使几乎所有的英国部队撤退。只剩下一个单位，那就是第一南威尔士边防团，他们在压倒性的火力下坚守格卢韦尔城堡。
And their colonel, who's called Henry Burley Leach, he sent a message, and he says, I desperately need help because Geliwelt is lost. Now at this point, this is probably as close as the British ever came on the Western Front to complete panic and disintegration. Later on, years after the war, the core commander who was called Douglas Haig, he later told George V, he said, I remember the crowds of fugitives who came back down the men in road, having thrown away everything they could, including their rifles and packs, in order to escape, with a look of absolute terror on their faces, such as I have never before seen on any human being's face. So it looks like the British are going to collapse. And the call goes out. We need reinforcements desperately. And there's only one unit held in reserve that can get there.
他们的指挥官名叫亨利·伯利·里奇，他发了一条消息，说：“我急需支援，因为格卢韦尔失守了。”此时此刻，这可能是英国人在西线战场上最接近彻底恐慌和解体的一次。战争结束多年后，当时名叫道格拉斯·黑格的军长后来对乔治五世说：“我记得那些沿门恩路逃回的难民人群，他们为了逃命，扔掉了所有能扔的东西，包括步枪和背包，他们的脸上带着一种绝对恐怖的表情，这种表情我以前在任何人类的脸上都没有见过。”所以看起来英国人要崩溃了。于是求援信号发出去了。我们急需增援。而预备队中唯一能赶到的部队只有一个。
And they are the second Worcesters. And the Worcesters are kind of your classic, old-fashioned county regiment, you know, sort of men with moustaches, all this. There are fewer than 400 of them. They'd fought very bravely a few days earlier. So they've been told they're going to be resting. They're not being put into the line. As one of them later said, they're dog-tired, cold, wet, plastered with mud. They haven't washed or shaved for days. And at one o'clock, they're told, actually, you know what?
他们就是第二伍斯特郡团。伍斯特郡团可以说是你所能想象的经典、老式的郡团，你知道的，就是那种留着胡子的男人，诸如此类。他们的人数不到400人。几天前他们曾英勇作战。所以他们被告知他们将会休息。他们没有被投入一线。正如其中一人后来所说，他们疲惫不堪、寒冷、湿透、满身泥浆。他们已经好几天没洗脸没刮胡子了。下午一点，他们被告知，其实你知道吗？
You're not resting. We need you. They're brought forward to the front line. They're given some rum and some stew. And they're told, you have to fight to the chateau. Maybe the South Wales border is still there. Maybe they're not. But basically, if they are, you've got to save them. You've got to get to this chateau. And it's a terrifying prospect, because they have to cross these open fields. They have to cross a stream. They're under enemy shell fire. There's no cover. They've got to get to this Chateau and save the British Empire, these 400 blokes. So at 145, they fix their bayonets, and their major, who's called Edward Hankey, says, come on, lads, let's just go for it. So they charge across this field. There's horrendous German fire coming at them. About a hundred of
你们没有在休息。我们需要你们。他们被带到了前线。他们得到了一些朗姆酒和炖菜。他们被告知，你们必须为城堡而战。也许南威尔士边防团还在那里。也许不在。但基本上，如果在的话，你们必须拯救他们。你们必须到达这座城堡。这是一个令人毛骨悚然的前景，因为他们必须穿过这些开阔的田野。他们必须穿过一条小溪。他们正遭受敌人的炮火袭击。没有任何掩护。这400个家伙必须到达这座城堡并拯救大英帝国。因此，在14点45分，他们上了刺刀，他们的少校名叫爱德华·汉基，他说：“来吧，伙计们，我们冲吧。”于是他们冲过了这片田野。可怕的德国火力向他们袭来。大约有一百人
them hit, killed or wounded. The rest of them just keep going. They go over this stream. They go over a railway line. They go over some hedges. And then they're through a wire fence. And then, and I quote, we cut through it as best we could at length the chateau grounds and there was the hun right enough but we had surprised him he hadn't seen us coming there was a cheer and we charged
被击中，阵亡或受伤。其余的人继续前进。他们跨过这条小溪。他们越过一条铁路线。他们穿过一些树篱。然后他们穿过了一道铁丝网。接着，我引述道：“我们尽最大努力穿过去，终于到了城堡的场地，德国佬就在那里，千真万确，但我们袭击了他个措手不及，他没有看到我们走过来，一片欢呼声中我们冲了上去。”
and that's not me talking Tom it's Captain Boucher Campbell Senhouse Clark great name great guy so the Germans are swept from the field because they weren't expecting these blokes to turn up
这不是我在说，汤姆，这是布歇·坎贝尔·森豪斯·克拉克上尉，好名字，好家伙。所以德国人被赶出了战场，因为他们没有料到这些家伙会突然出现。
Major Hankey of course blows his hunting horn and the South Wales borderers who've been there all the time holding out in the chateau, they emerge from the chateau. Hurrah, great scenes. And then I think one of the great moments in all history, Major Hanky realizes that Colonel Leach is an old friend of his from his hunting days.
汉基少校当然吹起了他的狩猎号角，一直在城堡里坚守的南威尔士边防团从城堡里走了出来。乌拉，伟大的场景。然后我认为这是所有历史中最伟大的时刻之一，汉基少校意识到里奇上校是他打猎时期的老朋友。
And he says, well, they'd been to, I think one of them had been to Eaton and the other had been to Uppingham, but they'd surely played each other. Well, maybe gone fox hunting. Maybe they've gone fox hunting, exactly. Anyway, Major Hanky holds out his hand to Colonel Leach, and he says the most British thing in history. He says, my God, fancy me to you here. So it's a great victory, Tom, I'm happy to say, for our historic public schools. But also, it's a great victory for the British Empire.
他说，好吧，他们去过，我想其中一个人去过伊顿公学，另一个人去过乌平汉姆公学，但他们肯定一起玩过……好吧，也许去过狐狸狩猎。也许他们去过狐狸狩猎，确实如此。不管怎样，汉基少校向里奇上校伸出手，说出了历史中最英国式的话。他说：“天哪，真没想到在这里见到你。”所以，汤姆，我很高兴地说，这是我们历史悠久的公立学校的伟大胜利。而且，这也是大英帝国的一场伟大胜利。
Because the really outstanding figure of the day, 31st of October 1914, is a machine gunner who was stationed in the nearby village of Hollebecker. Now, he was part of a six-man unit, and they'd come under unrelenting fire. He was hit in the arm, he was hit in the leg. but he kept on fighting, his sergeant was killed, the four other men in the unit were killed, so now it's just him, and he's surrounded by the lifeless bodies of his mates. He fights on, he's endangered being overrun by the Germans, so at the last minute he disables the gun, and he crawls away to safety under German fire. And this bloke's name was Kudad Khan, and he'd been born in 1888 in the Punjab, which was then
因为1914年10月31日那天真正出类拔萃的人物，是驻扎在附近霍勒贝克村的一名机枪手。当时，他是六人小组的一部分，他们遭到了不间断的火力攻击。他的手臂中弹，腿部中弹。但他继续战斗，他的班长阵亡了，小组中的其他四个人也阵亡了，所以现在只剩下他一个人，他周围全是没有生命的战友遗体。他继续战斗，面临被德国人包围的危险，于是在最后一刻，他使机枪失效，并在德国人的火力下爬行逃生。这个家伙的名字叫库达德·汗，他于1888年出生旁遮普，当时是
British India, now Pakistan. He'd enlisted in the Duke of Connought's own beluchies in August 1914, and he's one of one and a half million Indians, and indeed 400,000 Muslims who fought for Britain. And after this battle, Kududad Khan was shipped home to Brighton, where the Brighton Pavilion had been converted into a hospital for the Indian army. Was that because they thought that the Brighton Pavilion would remind the Indian troops of India? Do you know, I don't know. I've often wondered that. Surely, surely must have played a part. I mean, it's a very convenient building, but surely it must have played a part. And the Brighton Pavilion, I think it had different sections for kind of Sikhs, Hindus, Muslims and whatnot. It was all very carefully kind of planned. Anyway, when this bloke, he was recovered, he was invited to Buckingham Palace to receive the Victoria Cross from George V. And he was the first Muslim ever to win it. Heroic stuff from Kudad Khan, from the Worcesters, from their comrades, from the guy with the hunting horn, the whole set.
英属印度，现在是巴基斯坦。他于1914年8月加入了公爵的巴洛奇团，他是为英国作战的一百五十万印度人以及整整四十万穆斯林之一。这场战役之后，库达德·汗被遣返回布赖顿休养，布赖顿穹顶宫当时已被改建为印度军队的医院。那是以为布赖顿穹顶宫会让印度部队想起印度吗？你知道吗，我不知道。我经常纳闷这一点。当然，这肯定起到了作用。我的意思是，这是一座非常方便的建筑，但它肯定起到了作用。而且布赖顿穹顶宫，我想它有不同的区域，分别针对锡克教徒、印度教徒、穆斯林等等。这一切都经过了非常仔细的规划。无论如何，当这个人恢复健康后，他被邀请去白金汉宫接受乔治五世颁发的维多利亚十字勋章。他是获得该勋章的第一位穆斯林。来自库达德·汗、伍斯特郡团、他们的战友以及吹号角的那个人，所有这些都是英雄般的事迹。
And the drama is that I'm guessing the British hold on, that they maintain the Eap salient, whether it's a triangle or a square or a circle. We haven't absolutely decided, but we've definitely decided that tremendous heroism has been shown. And that's the key thing. But Dominic, I'm guessing the Germans haven't given up. No. And after the break, Tom, they will make another attempt. They will throw the dice one last time. This episode is brought to you by Uber.
而戏剧性的是，我猜英国人坚守住了，他们守住了伊珀尔突出部，无论它是一个三角形、正方形还是圆形。我们还没有完全决定，但我们绝对已经确定，展现出了巨大的英雄主义。而这才是关键所在。但是，多米尼克，我猜德国人并没有放弃。没有。中场休息后，汤姆，他们会再次尝试。他们将最后一次掷骰子。本集由优步为您带。
Now, do you know that feeling when someone shows up for you when you need it most? We all need that sometimes. And Uber knows it. Uber isn't just a ride or a meal delivered. It's showing up no matter what. Like for your long distance friends, bringing soon. soup when they're sick, sending flowers when they're down. When it really matters, whatever it is, you show up.
现在，你知道那种当你在最需要的时候有人为你出现的感觉吗？我们有时都需要那种感觉。优步知道这一点。优步不仅仅是一次行程或一顿外卖。它是在无论发生什么时都为你出现。比如为了你的异地朋友，带着快。汤当他们生病时，在他们情绪低落时送上鲜花。当真正重要的时候，无论是什么，你都会出现。
Where there's a will, we're on our way. Uber, on our way. Download the app today. This episode is brought to you by the Folio Society. Now, Thomas, you know, in the Middle Ages, it could take you years if you're a monk to create a manuscript. You'd have to copy it out word by word. And after all that, the margins would be ready and you'd put all kind of decorative elements and all kinds of gills and stuff in the margins and it would look fantastic. So it might take often years to finish, but the finished product would then last for centuries. And that is pretty much what the Folio Society does today, only, of course, with slightly less parchment and fewer quills.
有志者，事竟成。优步，在路上。立即下载应用程序。本集由福里奥学会为您呈献。现在，托马斯，你知道的，在中世纪，如果你是一名僧侣，创造一份手稿可能需要你几年的时间。你必须逐字复制。在做完这一切之后，页边距就会准备好，你会在页边距中添加各种装饰元素和各种贴金之类的东西，它看起来会棒极了。所以完成它通常需要几年时间，但成品可以使用几个世纪。这几乎就是福里奥学会今天在做的事情，当然，只不过用的羊皮纸和羽毛笔稍微少了一点。
Yes, the Folio Society takes some of the greatest works ever written, things like George Orwell's 1984 or the quests in J.R. Hulkeen or Frank Herbert's June and their team of editors and designers and artisans. They craft books that are so beautiful. They're like works of art in their own right. So each one is carefully designed with slipcases, award-winning illustrations, and covers that honor the stories inside. It doesn't just protect them. So if like me and like Tom, you think that a book should look as good as it reads,
是的，福里奥学会收集了一些有史以来最伟大的著作，比如乔治·奥威尔的《1984》或J·R·托尔金的探险或弗兰克·赫伯特的《沙丘》，以及他们的编辑、设计师和工匠团队。他们制作的书籍非常精美。它们本身就像艺术品一样。因此，每本书都经过精心设计，配有书盒、屡获殊荣的插图以及向书中故事致敬的封面。它不仅保护它们。因此，如果你和我以及汤姆一样，认为一本书看起来应该和读起来一样好，
then the Folio Society very much speaks your language. Explore the world's most loved stories in the most beautiful form, only at foliosociety.com. That is foliosociety.com. Welcome back to the rest is history. Dominic, as ever we left listeners on a cliffhanger. The Germans are about to roll the dice again. How do the dice fall?
那么福里奥学会非常合你的心意。探索世界上最受喜爱的故事，领略它们最美丽的形态，尽在 foliosociety.com。网址是 foliosociety.com。欢迎回到《历史的 rest》。多米尼克，和往常一样，我们把听众留在了悬念之中。德国人即将再次掷骰子。骰子是怎么落下的？
So we're now into November. The weather has definitely turned. It's pouring with rain. It's very cold. The trenches are kind of knee-deep in mud. And on the 5th of November, Germanist Supreme Commander Eric von Falkenheim says, one more go.
我们现在进入了11月。天气明显变坏了。下着倾盆大雨。天气非常冷。战壕里的泥浆齐膝深。11月5日，德国最高指挥官埃里希·冯·法金汉说：“再试一次。”
And he orders a new wave of assaults on the E Prasalient, and they're battering again and again away at these lines with a colossal loss of life. Both sides now are really running on empty. The front line officers are begging all the time. My men need to rest. You know, there's a real, weariness to it. And a sense of if there was any last vestige of romance about this, it has long
他下令对伊珀尔突出部发起新一轮的攻势，他们一次又一次地对这些防线进行猛烈轰炸，造成了巨大的生命损失。双方现在都真正精疲力竭了。前线军官一直在乞求。我的部下需要休息。你知道的，有一种真正的疲惫感。并且有一种感觉，如果关于这还有哪怕一丝一缕的浪漫色彩的话，那也早就
since disappeared. So Max Hastings tells the story of the German 143rd infantry. They went down the Mennon Road, this sort of crucial road, with their regimental band playing Deutschland Uber Alas song that we began with. And British fire ripped into them. Lots of the musicians were killed and they were forced backwards. And when they got back, the band were all ordered. hand over your instruments, you won't be using those again. And they were told, you know, your days of, you know, blowing trumpets are over. You have to retrain as stretcher bearers. And as Max Hastings says, it feels like a very symbolic moment, kind of handing over your trumpet and being given a stretcher. There are a couple more days of punishing assaults on the 10th and the 11th. Falconheim's last attempt, really, a massive artillery bombardment. Yet again, he throws thousands of men down this men in road. A couple of places the Germans briefly break through, but they're British were able to sort of plug the gaps. Again, there are countless kind of really haunting stories. So one of them is there's a guy called William Holbrook, who's a corporal and the royal fuseliers, and his platoon were pinned down in no man's land. And at one point, he said,
消失殆尽了。所以马克斯·黑斯廷斯讲述了德国第143步兵团的故事。他们沿着门恩路（这条至关重要的路）前进，他们的军乐队演奏着我们开始时听到的《德意志高于一切》的歌曲。英国人的火力向他们倾泻而许多音乐家被炸死，他们被迫往后撤。当他们撤回后，乐队全体被命令：交出你们的乐器，你们以后不会再用到这些了。他们被告知，你知道的，你们吹小号的日子已经结束了。你们必须重新接受培训，成为担正如马克斯·黑斯廷斯所说，这感觉像是一个非常具有象征意义的时刻，交出小号，换上担架。在10日和11日，还有几天的惩罚性猛烈攻击。法金汉的最后一次尝试，实际上是一次大规模的炮兵轰炸。他又一次将成千上万的人投入这条门恩路。在几个地方，德国人短暂地突破了，但英国人能够设法堵住缺口。再次强调，有无数真正令人难忘的故事。其中一个故事是，有一个叫威廉·霍尔布鲁克的家伙，他是皇家步枪团的一名下士，他的排被困在无人区动弹不得。有一次，他说，
a German officer crawled out of the bushes and said in perfect English, I am wounded. And the fuseliers lieutenant shouted, great banter, he shouted, you shouldn't make these bloody attacks, then he wouldn't get wounded. And everybody laughs. And then a bullet smacks him to the lieutenant's head and blows it off so they're not laughing now. And later Holbrook crawls into a crater, a shell crater for cover. And in it he finds a German, a wounded German soldier who begs him for water in German. Holbrook gives him some water. The bloke drinks this water and it just pours out of a hole in his side. And the German holds up three fingers and he says to Holbrook, Kleinerkinder, meaning I've got three small children. And then
一个德国军官从灌木丛中爬出来，用流利的英语说：“我受伤了。”步枪团的中尉大声喊道，真是开玩笑，他大喊：“那你们就不该发起这血腥的进攻，那样你就不会受伤了。”所有人都笑了。接着一颗子弹击中了中尉的头部，把头轰飞了，所以他们现在笑不出来了。后来霍尔布鲁克爬进了一个弹坑，一个用来躲避的炮弹坑。在里面他发现了一个德国人，一个受伤的德国士兵，用德语向他乞求水。霍尔布鲁克给了他一些水。那家伙喝了这水，水直接从他侧面的一个洞里流了出来。那个德国人举起三个手指对霍尔布鲁克说：“Kleinerkinder”，意思是“我有三个小孩子”。然后
Holbrook just sits with him until this bloke dies, and then when darkness falls, he crawls back to the British Lions. And there are loads of stories like this. Anyway, this day ends like all the others. The Germans almost break through, but they haven't quite. And by now, both sides have run out of shells and the men just can't go on. And the weather is now so awful, howling winds, blizzards of snow, that mass assaults are just completely unrealistic. And the fighting sort of drags on in a very to sultry way until about the 25th of November, when Falkenheim says, he issues an order to all German forces in the West. Okay, we're done for the year. Hold your ground, dig in, and we'll wait until the Thor comes in the new year. By this point, have both the Germans
霍布拉克一直陪着他，直到这家伙咽了气。天黑后，他又爬回了英国远征军阵地。像这样的故事还有很多。总之，这一天像其他日子一样结束了。德军差点突破防线，但功亏一篑。到了现在，双方的炮弹都打光了，士兵们实在支撑不下去了。天气也变得恶劣之极，狂风呼啸，暴雪纷至沓来，大规模进攻已完全不切实际。战斗以一种极其沉闷的方式一直拖延到11月25日左右，当时法尔肯海因下达了一道命令，发给西线的所有德军部队。好了，今年的仗打完了。坚守阵地，就地筑垒，我们等到新年天气回暖再说。到了这个时候，德国人、法国人和英国人是不是把战壕一直挖到了海岸？
and the French and the British dug trenches all the way to the coast? Yes, the trench lines now are complete. So they run from the coast, effectively, all the way down to the Swiss border. I know you, of course, Tom would go through Switzerland. Yes, the unimaginative German high command have failed to seize that opportunity. They have failed to seize it. So, Ibrahim has been a victory for the Allies, no question. They've kept Ipe, although it's been completely reduced to rubble the cloth hall in ruins, whatever. They've kept the channel ports.
是的，战壕线现在已经连成一片了。它们实际上从海岸一直延伸到瑞士边境。当然，我知道你，汤姆，会穿过瑞士。是的，缺乏想象力的德国最高指挥部没能抓住这个机会。他们没能抓住机会。因此，对盟军来说，伊珀尔之战是一场胜利，毫无疑问。他们守住了伊珀尔，尽管它已经完全变成了一片废墟，布商会馆也成了残垣断壁，等等。他们守住了海峡港口。
They've kept this salient to the east, although this is now means it's going to come for the next four years under unrelenting fire from the German guns. And presumably already by this point is just mud. Yeah, exactly, been churned up into nothing. But the cost is enormous. So out of 160,000 men that the British had, they've lost about 60,000 killed, wounded and missing. So that's a casualty rate of more than 30% unsustainable in the long run. The Belgians have lost a third of their army. The French, at Ipe alone have lost 50,000 men. And the German losses at Ip. They lost 140,000 men at Eap. Most of them wounded or missing, but 25,000. And that's because they're the ones doing. the attacking. They're the ones doing the attacking. The attacking is what gets you. And this is obviously just a fraction of the total death toll. So to give you a sense, the British in four months, and don't forget the British are by far the smallest army. They have lost 90,000 men, killed, wounded and captured. So many officers, it's often, you know, this thing about lions led by donkeys, it's actually the officers who take most of the casualties because they're leading from the front.
他们守住了东部的突出部，尽管这意味着在接下来的四年里，这里将遭受德军炮火无情的轰击。而且可以想象，此时这里肯定已经是一片泥泞。是的，没错，被搅得什么都不剩了。但代价是巨大的。在英国拥有的16万军队中，大约有6万名士兵阵亡、受伤和失踪。伤亡率超过了30%，从长远来看这是不可持续的。比利时人损失了三分之一的军队。仅在伊珀尔，法国人就损失了5万名士兵。而德军在伊珀尔的损失呢。他们在伊珀尔损失了14万名士兵。其中大多数人受伤或失踪，但有2.5万人阵亡。这是因为他们是进攻的一方。他们是进攻的一方。发起进攻才是导致伤亡的原因。这显然只是总死亡人数的一小部分。为了让你有个概念，英国人在四个月里——别忘了英国军队是其中规模最小的——已经损失了9万名阵亡、受伤和被俘的士兵。有那么多的军官……人们常说“群狮由驴子率领”，但实际上付出大部分伤亡代价的恰恰是军官，因为他们总是冲在最前面。
So so many officers from aristocratic families have died. Forty-seven people. people have died who were heirs to aristocratic titles, that John Buckin said that reading the casualty lists in the Times was like scanning the death roll after Agincourt or Flodden. In other words, the flower of the nobility has been destroyed. And in fact, the BEF generally, the old BEF that had sailed to France and that, you know, they'd been kind of joshing with people at railway stations and accepting gifts of flowers, that's pretty much being destroyed. You know, huge numbers of those men have been killed or wounded.
因此，许多来自贵族家庭的军官阵亡了。有四十七位拥有贵族头衔继承权的年轻人都阵亡了，正如约翰·巴肯所说，在《泰晤士报》上阅读阵亡名单就像是在翻阅阿金库尔战役或弗洛登战役后的阵亡名册。换句话说，贵族的精粹已经被摧毁了。事实上，英国远征军总体而言，那支驶往法国的老牌英国远征军——他们曾在火车站和人们开玩笑、接受鲜花馈赠的那支部队——基本上已经被消灭了。你知道，其中数量庞大的士兵已经阵亡或负伤。
And so at home, Kitchener, the War Minister is now raising what becomes imaginatively to be called the new army. But not the new model army. Not the new model army. That would have been a grey name. And so this is when his recruiting poster starts to go up. Exactly. So there's a huge recruitment drive now. But of course, that's Britain.
因此在国内，战争大臣基舍尔现在正在组建后来被称为“新陆军”的部队。但不是“新模范军”。不是“新模范军”。那会是一个很棒的名字。所以，这就是他的征兵海报开始张贴的时候。没错。因此，现在有一场大规模的征兵运动。但当然，那是英国。
But for the French and the Germans, the casualties are far higher. Each of those combatants has lost about half a million men killed, wounded or captured. And for the Germans who were particularly keen to get this done and dusted quickly because they're so anxious about the allied manpower advantage, obviously the Russians, this is particularly worrying. And so this, I think, starts to explain the story we began with, the young men singing as they go into battle. This idea of the kindermode, the death of the children. So in Britain, it's usually translated as the massacre of the innocence. Tom, you'll know all about this. This is your bailiwick.
但对法德两国来说，伤亡要惨重得多。交战双方各自损失了大约五十万名阵亡、受伤或被俘的士兵。对于急于速战速决的德国人来说，由于他们非常担心盟军的人力优势——显然还有俄国人，这尤其令人担忧。因此，我认为这开始解释我们最初提到的故事：年轻人唱着歌走上战场。这种“儿童大屠杀”（Kindermord）的概念，即孩子们的死亡。所以在英国，它通常被翻译为“无辜者的屠杀”。汤姆，你对这个一定很了解。这是你的专长。
biblical massacres. Yes, the children being massacred on the orders of Herod, which we talked about in our episode on the origins of the blood libel. Exactly. So I guess you could call this a meme, a cultural artifact that goes through loads of different variations as it spreads. And it spreads in the last days at the Battle of Eap, and then it gathers momentum. And by the time Hitler borrowed it, so he's writing Mein Kampf in 1924, at that point, he's basically ripping it off because it was familiar to every thinking German. It's become a hallowed part of their national wartime mythology. And so what's the thinking?
圣经中的大屠杀。是的，根据希律王的命令孩子们被屠杀，我们在关于血腥诬告起源的那期节目中谈到过。没错。所以我想你可以称之为一个迷因（meme），一个在传播过程中经历大量不同变体的文化产物。它在伊珀尔战役的最后几天传播开来，然后积蓄了势头。当希特勒借用它时——他在1924年撰写《我的奋斗》时——到了那个时候，他基本上是在抄袭，因为它对每个有思想的德国人来说都耳熟能详。它已经成为他们国家战时神话中神圣不可侵犯的一部分。那么，当时的考量是什么？
Is Hitler making, I mean, is Hitler's reminiscence is authentic or is he molding them to suit the form of the myth or what's going on? I think there probably is an element of authenticity in them, actually. I think he's undoubtedly molding them as people do. But as we will see, a lot of German historians now hate this story. And they say this story is pure, it's sinister propaganda. But as we will see, there is a definite element of truth to it. So the most common version of the meme is that the date is given us the 10th November
希特勒是在……我是说，希特勒的回忆是真实的，还是他在为了迎合神话的形式而塑造它们？到底是怎么回事？我认为其中实际上确实带有真实性成分。我认为他毫无疑问像其他人一样对它们进行了塑造。但正如我们将会看到的，许多德国历史学家现在对这个故事恨之入骨。他们说这个故事纯粹是阴险的宣传。但正如我们将会看到的，其中确实含有明确的真实成分。因此，这个迷因最常见的版本是：日期被定为11月10日
and it's heavy fog and a German unit is advancing on the village of Langermark. And these are student volunteers, so the story goes. They're so young that their comrades have nicknamed them the children's core. And they're advancing through the fog and the British Open Fire at them sithing through their ranks. The survivors, these young lads, dropped to the ground, they're paralyzed with fear. then one of them starts to sing Deutschland, Deutschland Uber Alice and then another joins in
当时浓雾弥漫，一个德军连队正在向兰格马克村推进。故事是这样说的，这些都是学生志愿者。他们太年轻了，以至于战友们给他们取了个外号叫“儿童军”。他们在浓雾中前进，英国人向他们开火，子弹像割草一样穿过他们的队列。幸存下来的这些年轻小伙子倒在地上，吓得动弹不得。然后其中一个人开始唱《德国，德国，高于一切》，接着另一个人加入进来，
and then another and then as one they get up and they start to run at the enemy trenches ignoring the enemy fire. A lot of them lost their helmets but they don't care they just keep going one account says they are like unreal figures from an old saga and
然后又一个人，接着他们异口同声地站起来，开始向敌人的战壕冲去，全然不顾敌人的火力。许多人弄丢了钢盔，但他们不在乎，只是继续前进。有一份记载称，他们就像旧传奇中不真实的幻影，
some versions they storm the British trenches but more typically they're shot down one by one and the song finally fades away And so you can sort of see why, you know, a nation raised on Richard Wagner and inspiring stories of Teutonic Knights are going to love this story. I mean, what's interesting about it, it prefigures what is what in Britain is probably the most famous myth that arises from the first world of the lot, which is the Christmas truce. And again, there is that idea of a lone voice starting to sing a song, then other voices picking up. And then this is a story of peace rather than of war.
在某些版本中，他们攻占了英国战壕，但更典型的是，他们一个接一个地被击毙，歌声最终渐渐消散。所以你可以理解，为什么一个在理查德·瓦格纳和条顿骑士励志故事熏陶下长大的国家会喜欢这个故事。有趣的是，它预示了英国一战中可能最著名的神话的诞生，那就是圣诞节休战。同样，也有这样一个场景：一个孤独的声音开始唱歌，然后其他声音加入进来。这是一个关于和平而非战争的故事。
But again, there is the thing that at the end, the singing fades away and the guns start firing again. And it has the same kind of rhythm, doesn't it? That hadn't occurred to me, actually, but I think that's a really good point. So it's very tempting to say, well, this is obviously made up. It's obviously pure propaganda. But actually, there's a guy called Robert Cowley, who's done brilliant detective work on this. And I commend his article of the military history quarterly. So in this article, he traces this story to an official, a German army bulletin,
但同样，最后歌声渐渐消散，枪声再度响起。它有着相同的节奏，不是吗？我之前没想到这一点，但我认为这是一个非常精辟的观点。所以人们很容易说，好吧，这显然是编造的。这显然是纯粹的宣传。但实际上，有个叫罗伯特·考利的人，他在研究这方面做出了出色的侦探式工作。我向大家推荐他在《军事历史季刊》上发表的文章。在这篇文章中，他将这个故事追溯到了一份官方的德国陆军公报，
which was printed the next day, the 11th of November, and ended up on loads of newspaper front pages. And the newspaper's story said, West of Langermark, youthful regiment stormed the first lines of the enemy trenches and took them singing, Deutschland, Deutsche,deutsland, Uber Alice. Now, actually, as he points out, we know this didn't happen.
该公报于次日（即11月11日）印刷，并最终登上了许多报纸的头版。报纸上的报道说：“在兰格马克以西，年轻的团冲破了敌人战壕的第一线，高唱着《德国，德国，高于一切》攻占了阵地。”现在，正如他所指出的，我们知道这并没有发生。
No volunteer units captured allied trenches at Langermark that day. So that's why a lot of German historians now, and you can completely see why, they dismissed this whole story, And they said this is a nationalistic fantasy, it's a prefiguring a Nazism, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. But actually, Cowley says, you know what, there are loads of allied accounts of Germans singing as they go into battle. There's one at Zonabecher in the 21st of October. A British soldier says Germans came out of singing, waving their rifles.
那天没有任何志愿者部队在兰格马克攻占盟军的战壕。这就是为什么许多德国历史学家现在——你完全可以理解为什么——驳斥了整个故事，他们说这是一个民族主义的幻想，是纳粹主义的预兆，等等等等。但实际上，考利说，你知道吗，有很多盟军关于德国人唱着歌走向战场的记录。10月21日在佐纳贝克有一份记录。一名英国士兵说德国人唱着歌走出来，挥舞着步枪。
We shot them down, but they were incredibly brave. The next day, 22nd of October, the Gloucesters. They fought a German volunteer unit. They advanced with the utmost determination singing patriotic songs and suffered appalling. casualties. And there are two accounts by a French colonel called Henri Collin, near a place called Big Shooter. He says, first of all, a load of Germans advanced singing, and we drove them off. They left a great number of corpses. And then on the 16th of October, and I quote, the young German recruits advance shoulder to shoulder in a column four men abreast and singing
我们开枪击倒了他们，但他们极其勇敢。第二天，即10月22日，格洛斯特郡团。他们与一个德国志愿者部队作战。他们以极大的决心唱着爱国歌曲向前推进，并付出了惨重的伤亡。法国上校亨利·科林在一个叫“大射手”的地方附近留下了两份记录。他说，首先，一大群德国人唱着歌前进，我们把他们打退了。他们留下了大量的尸体。然后在10月16日，我引述道：“年轻的德国新兵并肩前进，排成四列纵队，唱着
Deutschland Uber Alas. It was crazy. The human cost meant nothing to them. So the Allies aren't going to be making this stuff up. And Robert Cowdy says, what's going on here? He says, these are not blokes who are singing because they're suffused with a kind of Viking spirit to give their lives for their country. Actually, what's happened is, these are volunteers who Falcon Heinz thrown into the sort of the meat grinder. They have been very hastily trained, then rushed to the front. They are not really ready for what's coming at them. They're overwhelmed by the horror of it. They're probably singing for two reasons. One, to keep panic at bay to kind of desperately try to keep their spirits up. And number two, because the
《德国，德国，高于一切》。这太疯狂了。人类的代价对他们来说毫无意义。”所以盟军可不会凭空捏造这些东西。罗伯特·考利说，这到底是怎么回事？他说，这些家伙唱歌并不是因为他们充溢着一种献身祖国的维京精神。实际上，发生的情况是：这些是法尔肯海因扔进绞肉机里的志愿者。他们受过非常仓促的训练，然后被仓促派往前线。他们其实还没有为即将到来的一切做好准备。他们被战争的恐怖压垮了。他们唱歌大概有两个原因：第一，为了抑制恐慌，拼命振作精神；第二，因为
weather has changed, it's become very rainy and very foggy. And they're singing, as a lot of units did of all sides, to identify themselves to other units. So they're not shot by friendly fire. So in other words, this is not really a story about great melodramatic, patriotic enthusiasm. It's a one that expresses the terror and confusion of young men at the front. Now, the other thing Robert Cowley says is, first of all, it's probable that a lot of them are not singing Deutschland, Uber Alice. They're probably singing the song that Hitler mentions at the beginning of that passage, which is De Vacht Am Rhine, the Watch on the Rhine. That was the most popular German marching song. And the other thing, they're not children. They're not even
天气变了，变得又下雨又起雾。他们唱歌和各方许多部队一样是为了向其他部队表明身份，免得被友军误伤。换句话说，这并不是一个关于伟大、戏剧性、爱国热忱的故事，而是一个表达前线年轻人的恐惧和迷茫的故事。罗伯特·考利的另一个观点是，首先，他们中的许多人很可能唱的不是《德国，德国，高于一切》。他们可能唱的是希特勒在那段话开头提到的那首歌，即《莱茵河畔》，莱茵河守望歌。那是当时最流行的德国军歌。另一个事实是，他们不是孩子。他们甚至不是
students. Only one in five of these volunteers were students. They're actually just ordinary Germans. We'll come back to why they start to be referred to a student. Finally, it doesn't happen at Langermark. Why does the story end up being located here and here? Cowdy has this brilliant explanation, which is just so simple. He says, in German, to a German ear, most of these other villages have very unglamorous names. So, Big Shooter doesn't sound like a place
学生。这些志愿者中只有五分之一是学生。他们实际上只是普通的德国人。我们稍后会讨论为什么他们开始被称为学生。最后，这件事根本没有发生在兰格马克。为什么这个故事最终被安放在这个地方？考利有一个绝妙的解释，简单得令人发指。他说，在德国人听来，大多数其他村庄的名字都非常缺乏魅力。因此，“大射手”听起来并不像是一个适合
for a kind of Wagnerian self-immolation. But Langermark does. He quotes a former volunteer who was writing in 1933, who said of Langermark, the name sounds like a heroic. legend. So in other words, the story was placed here because it sounded really good. So how does the story come to play such a massive part in German propaganda? Obviously, the colossal loss of life is an important bit of the context, but there are two things about Eeper in particular. Number one, more than any other battle in 1914, this feels like a total waste of lives. Because
瓦格纳式慷慨赴义的地方。但“兰格马克”是。他引用了一位1933年撰文的前志愿者的话，那人谈到兰格马克时说：“这个名字听起来就像一个英雄传奇。”换句话说，故事被安放在这里是因为它听起来真的很棒。那么，这个故事是如何在德国宣传中扮演如此重要的角色的呢？显然，巨大的生命损失是背景中一个重要的部分，但关于伊珀尔有两点尤为特殊。第一，比1914年的任何其他战役都更让人觉得这是一场对生命的彻底浪费。因为
Falcon Hein is throwing thousands of men basically into the inferno and they haven't broken through. And this will become the prototype for the First World War battle that endures to this day, this image of mass slaughter that serves no purpose at all. Exactly. Because if you think about all the battles who talked about so far, Mons or the Battle of the Frontiers or, you know, Le Cato or especially the Marn, people are moving quite a lot. You know, the front line is ebbing and flowing, right, quite quickly. But here, the front line is stuck and people are sort of charging and they're being shot down. and then the next day they're trying again and this is going to be the theme, isn't it, until 1918? But for the British, they have not yet picked up on this theme because presumably for them,
法尔肯海因基本上把成千上万的人扔进了人间炼狱，而他们却没有突破防线。这将成为第一次世界大战战役的原型，并延续至今——这种毫无意义的大规模屠杀的形象。精确地说。因为如果你想想我们迄今为止谈论的所有战役，蒙斯、边境战役、勒卡托或者特别是马恩河战役，人们的移动相当频繁。你知道，前线正在相当快地起伏涨落，对吧？但在这里，前线卡住了，人们一边冲锋一边被击毙，然后第二天他们又重来一次，这将成为直到1918年的主题，不是吗？但对英国人来说，他们还没有抓住这个主题，因为对他们来说，大概
IPRA is a thermopylae that holds. Yeah, it's defensive. It's a defensive battle in which the defenders are massively outnumbered and yet the overwhelming force of the attackers can't break through. So is it the SOM that teaches them the lesson that the Germans have already learned in 1914? I think so. I think if you talk to a lot of British military,
伊珀尔是一座坚守住的温泉关。是的，这是一场防御战，防守方在人数上处于巨大的劣势，然而进攻方排山倒海的兵力却无法突破。那么，是索姆河战役给他们上了德国人在1914年就已经学会的一课吗？我想是的。我想如果你去问很多英国军事
historians now, they will say that basically what happens in the next few years is a learning curve. And the French finally figure it out in 1918, they win. But it takes a long time to get to that point. Going back to Ypres, the impact of that slaughter falls disproportionately on the Germans and on their reserve divisions of their young volunteers, divisions which actually end up losing about half their men. So as these stories go back to Germany, the newspapers in Germany are craving a bit of good news, a story that gives their sacrifice, a deeper meaning. So a story that will both inspire the men who are still in the trenches, but it will also reassure people back home. And so that is why this idea of the sacrifice
历史学家，他们会说，接下来的几年里基本上是一个学习曲线。法国人在1918年终于想明白了，他们赢得了胜利。但要达到那一点需要很长的时间。回到伊珀尔，那场大屠杀的影响不成比例地落在了德国人身上，落在了他们的后备师和年轻志愿者师身上，这些师实际上损失了大约一半的兵力。因此，当这些故事传回德国时，德国的报纸极渴望听到一点好消息，一个能赋予他们牺牲更深远意义的故事。所以这是一个既能激励仍在战壕里的士兵，又能安慰国内民众的故事。这就是为什么这种在
at Langermark has such traction. On the first anniversary of when this is supposed to have happened, which is the 10th of November, so in 1915, all the German papers celebrated the day of Langermark, and they said it should become a national day of remembrance. Of course, the irony is that it's the next day, the 11th, that in the long run becomes the day of remembrance across Europe. And once Germany lose the war in 1918, the idea of the Kindermort becomes incredibly powerful because it fits perfectly with the stab in the back legend. So it's our brave boys went singing into battle, but in the long run they were betrayed by communists and Jews and social democrats and, you know, civilian politicians and so on.
兰格马克的牺牲精神会产生如此巨大的影响力。在本应发生这件事的周年纪念日（即11月10日，也就是1915年），所有德国报纸都庆祝兰格马克日，并表示它应该成为一个全国性的纪念日。当然，具有讽刺意味的是，从长远来看，反而是第二天（即11日）成为了全欧洲的阵亡将士纪念日。一旦德国在1918年输掉了战争，“儿童大屠杀”（Kindermord）的概念就变得异常强大，因为它与“背后刺刀”的传说完美契合。也就是说，我们勇敢的小伙子们唱着歌走上战场，但从长远来看，他们被共产党人、犹太人、社会民主党人以及文职政客等等背叛了。
So in this idea of it as a massacre of the innocence, it's not so much the British who are playing the part of Herod in this narrative. It's the evil, I suppose, the Jews most obviously, because Herod was Jewish, but the guys back home who were profiteering. Yeah, I think so in the long run, certainly by the 1920s, when this story is being told, it's not an anglophobic story. In other words, the British is just doing their job firing their machine guns. But the real villains are the people who betrayed these young men. I think that's absolutely part of it. So in the 1920s, it's very popular with veterans groups, like the steel helmets, nationalistic veterans groups, but also student groups, who, as we know, are also very
因此，在这个关于无辜者大屠杀的观点中，在这段叙事中扮演希律王角色的与其说是英国人，不如说是那些邪恶之徒——显然最主要是犹太人，因为希律王是犹太人，但更是在后方发国难财的人。是的，我想长远来看确实如此，到了20世纪20年代这个故事被讲述的时候，这已经不是一个仇英的故事了。换句话说，英国人只是在尽职尽责地发射他们的机枪。但真正的恶棍是那些背叛了这些年轻人的家伙。我认为这绝对是其中一部分。所以在20世纪20年代，它在退伍军人团体中非常受欢迎，比如钢盔前线士兵同盟这样的民族主义退伍军人团体，还有学生团体，正如我们所知，他们在当时也非常
nationalistic in the 1920s and 30s. And it's given extra oomph by two things. So first of all, in 1922, the Deutschland, Leed, Deutscheland, Deutscheubert-Alice, was adopted as the anthem of the Weimar Republic. Before this, this had not been the German anthem. The German anthem was something called Heil Deer Imseiger Kranz, Hail to thee with the victor's crown. It was a kind of imperial anthem. And then in 1932, a huge German cemetery with more than 44,000 bodies, was dedicated at Langermark. 1932, of course,
在20世纪20到30年代具有强烈的民族主义色彩。两件事给它增添了额外的推动力。首先，在1922年，《德意志之歌》被采纳为魏玛共和国的国歌。在此之前，这并不是德国国歌。德国国歌是一首叫作《万岁，胜利者的花冠》的歌曲。那是一种帝国颂歌。然后，在1932年，一个拥有超过44,000具遗体的巨大德国公墓在兰格马克落成。当然，在1932年，
we know what's going to happen the following year, the advent of the Third Reich. And for Hitler and the Nazis, this story, it just seemed brilliant. It ticked every box for them. Youth, patriotism, struggle, sacrifice. The point about the student element is that students are such an important part of Hitler's coalition. Students love the Nazis. They can't wait to do a book burning. So when the Nazis get in, this story, this one moment becomes, dare I say, a sacral date. I think you absolutely can, yeah, in the Nazi religion.
我们知道第二年将会发生什么，那就是第三帝国的降临。对于希特勒和纳粹来说，这个故事简直太棒了。它完全符合他们的所有诉求：青年、爱国主义、斗争、牺牲。关于学生群体的一点是，学生是希特勒联盟中非常重要的组成部分。学生们狂热地热爱纳粹。他们迫不及待地想要进行焚书。所以当纳粹上台后，这个故事、这个特定的时刻变得——我敢说——具有了神圣的色彩。我想你完全可以这么说，是的，在纳粹的宗教中。
And I suppose also the fact that Hitler had been a participant in the First Battle of Ipe. I mean, it sanctifies him with the memory. of these soldiers who had died. I mean, who can say whether Hitler was ever in an offensive where people sang songs? Well, I mean, it's perfectly plausible that he could have been. And, I mean, there is a degree of cynicism to this,
我想还有这样一个事实：希特勒曾亲身参与过第一次伊珀尔战役。我的意思是，这用这些阵亡士兵的记忆神圣化了他。我的意思是，谁能说希特勒是否曾在人们唱歌的进攻中待过？好吧，我的意思是，他完全有可能经历过。而且，我的意思是，这里面带有一点讽刺意味，
but I think if you had asked him, if you had been having tea with a furor like your mate, what's her name, Unity Mitford, then he would have said that it did happen and he would probably have believed that it happened, even if it didn't. You know, he'd have convinced himself that he was part of it.
但我想如果你去问他，如果你曾和元首一起喝茶，就像你的好朋友——叫什么名字来着？尤妮蒂·米特福德那样，那么他会说这确实发生过，而且他很可能会相信这真的发生过，即使它并未发生。你知道的，他会说服自己他曾参与其中。
It would be part of his personal mythology of his involvement in the First World War, which plays such a huge part in his psychology. Anyway, from 1933, this was the day in which students were traditionally inducted into the Nazi Party the 10th of November, and every member of the Hitler youth had to pay a levy called the Langermark Fenig, the Langermark Penny. Robert Cowley in his article quotes a Nazi propagandist, National Socialism and Langermark are one and the same. So, to go back to 1914, when people find out you're a historian and the subject of the First World War comes up, people often ask this question, why did they carry on?
这将成为他个人神话的一部分，即他参与第一次世界大战的经历，这在他的心理中占据了极其重要的地位。无论如何，从1933年起，这就是传统上学生加入纳粹党的日子——11月10日，每一位希特勒青年团的成员都必须缴纳一种名为“兰格马克芬尼”的赋税。罗伯特·考利在他的文章中引用了一位纳粹宣传员的话：“国家社会主义和兰格马克是一回事。”所以，回到1914年，当人们发现你是一位历史学家并且话题转到第一次世界大战时，人们经常会问这样一个问题：他们为什么要坚持下去？
Why at the end of 1914 didn't they just all stop and agree to go home? And I think this story actually in some ways helps to answer that because the point is the scale of the slaughter and the sacrifice makes it harder to stop the war because you've sacrificed so many young men that it has. to mean something. You know, it can't all have been for nothing. The sacrifice must have been worth some kind of existential goal. The other thing I think about this question is that it's actually based on a false premise, which is that when people ask, why on earth do they keep going, the implication is, didn't they realize at this point that it was all for nothing, that it was all futile? I think you used the word futile earlier, didn't you, when you were saying about the perception of futile attacks and a futile war and stuff. But the French and the Germans
为什么在1914年底，他们没有直接停下来并同意回家？我认为这个故事在某种程度上实际上有助于回答这个问题，关键在于屠杀和牺牲的规模使得停止战争变得更加困难，因为你已经牺牲了如此多的年轻年轻人，这就必须具有某种意义。你知道的，这一切不可能都是白白牺牲的。这种牺牲一定是为了实现某种生存目标。关于这个问题的另一个想法是，它其实建立在一个错误的前提之上，那就是当人们问“他们到底为什么要坚持下去”时，其暗示的意思是：难道他们当时没有意识到这一切都是徒劳的，这一切都没有意义吗？我想你刚才用过“徒劳”这个词，不是吗？当你谈到对徒劳的进攻和徒劳的战争的看法之类的时候。但法国人和德国人
are the two most heavily committed countries. They don't think it's futile. at all. So if you're French, right, at this point, end of 1914, you haven't got Alsace and Lorraine back. And what's worse, the Germans have taken another 10th of your territory. They've taken a sixth of your manufacturing industry. They've taken all of your iron and steel. They've got 8 million acres of your most fertile farmland. Of course you're not going to stop. You know, it's like saying to the Ukrainians, why don't you stop? Of course you're not going to stop when they've got your territory. And as for the Germans, they went into this thinking this was life or death, right?
是参战程度最深的两个国家。他们一点也不觉得这很徒劳。所以，如果你是一个法国人，对吧，在此时——1914年底，你还没有收回阿尔萨斯和洛林。更糟的是，德国人又占领了你十分之一的领土。他们夺走了你六分之一的制造业。他们夺走了你所有的铁和钢铁。他们控制了你800万英亩最肥沃的农田。你当然不会停下来。你知道的，这就好比对乌克兰人说：“你们为什么不停下来？”当他们占领了你的领土时，你当然不会停下来。至于德国人，他们参战时认为这是生死攸关的问题，对吧？
That's what Malka thought. It's what the Kaiser thought. It's what Bettmann-Holveg thought. And so they still think that. Of course, they still think it. A lot of people have died. They've got the French and the Russians in arms on both sides of them. They think, but of course, we're not going to just go home.
小毛奇是这么想的，德皇是这么想的，贝特曼-霍尔维格也是这么想的。所以他们仍然这么认为。当然，他们依然这么认为。许多人已经阵亡了。法国人和俄人在他们两侧兵戎相见。他们心想，但当然，我们绝不能就这样回家。
Because, actually, you know, Tom, we know what happens when they lost. Yeah, it wasn't good. Yeah. So they're thinking, of course, we've got to keep going and try to win somehow. But of course, what they all know now is that this is going to be very long and very brutal. So you mentioned this already. In the American football, so American listeners will enjoy this, they have a saying that defense wins championships.
因为事实上，你知道，汤姆，我们知道他们战败后会发生什么。是的，那可不好。是的。所以他们在想，当然，我们必须坚持下去，想方设法赢得胜利。但当然，他们现在都知道这将是一场漫长而残酷的战争。所以你刚才已经提到了这一点。在美式橄榄球中——所以美国听众会喜欢这个——他们有句俗语叫“防守赢得冠军”。
And this is true of the First World War as much as it is of their ludicrous game. Because if you attack, right, the lesson of the Schlefen plan is, you will probably outrun your supply lines, you'll get exhausted, and then you'll be vulnerable. And actually, even in a small scale, if you attack, you'll probably end up stuck on some bar wire being riddled with machine gun bullets while a shell lands on your head. So in other words, both sides are basically, well, we're going to have to fight a kind of defensive strategy. They're digging in, deep trenches, sandbags, all this kind of thing.
这对于第一次世界大战来说同样适用，就像对他们那场荒谬的比赛一样。因为如果你进攻，对吧，施里芬计划给我们的教训就是：你很可能会超出自给补给线，精疲力竭，然后变得不堪一击。事实上，即便在小规模战斗中，如果你发起进攻，你很可能会最终被困在铁丝网某处，被机枪子弹打成筛子，同时还有一颗炮弹落在你的头上。换句话说，交战双方基本上都在想：好吧，我们将不得不采取某种防御战略。他们在构筑工事、深挖战壕、堆沙包，诸如此类。
And for older commanders who've known different kinds of war, this is a real shock. So Kitchener said a few months later, I just don't know what is to be done. This isn't war, as I understand it. You could say, oh, ha, ha, you know, look at this old man, completely clapped out and integrated, but that's very unfair. he was born in 1850. He'd fought in Egypt and in the Sudan. He'd won the Battle of Ombudsman, hadn't he?
对于那些经历过不同战争形态的老指挥官来说，这简直是一个巨大的震撼。因此，基辛格几个月后说：“我简直不知道该怎么办了。这根本不是我所理解的战争。”你可以说：“噢，哈哈，你看这个老头，已经完全精疲力竭、落伍了。”但这很不公平。他出生于1850年。他在埃及和苏丹打过仗。他赢得了恩图曼战役，不是吗？
He had. How could he possibly know? How could you possibly work out? You know, with that experience, how you're going to win a war like this, which is unprecedented. I mean, I suppose if the Mardi had had machine guns as well.
他确实赢了。他怎么可能知道？你怎么可能想得出来？凭借那种经验，你要如何赢得这样一场史无前例的战争。我的意思是，如果马赫迪人当时也有机枪的话……
Might have been a different story. It might have been a different story and he might have had time to think about it. Do you know what? Every podcast we ever do is in danger which is generating into a podcast about General Gordon. I know.
那可能会是另一个故事了。那可能会是另一个故事，而且他可能就会有时间去思考了。你知道吗？我们做的每一期播客都有变成一期关于戈登将军的播客的危险。我懂的。
He's always lurking in the background. He lives rent-free in our head. as the youngsters say. Right. So we started with the Germans, let's end with them. Now, you might expect them to be completely despondent because they've been told all this time that the Schlieffen-Molka plan
他总是潜伏在背景里。正如年轻人所说，他免费住在我们的脑海里。好。所以我们以德国人开头，让我们也以他们结尾。现在，你可能会期望他们完全沮丧，因为他们一直被告知施里芬-小毛奇计划
is the only way they're going to win. On the opposite side, they're entrenched in French and Belgian territory. They can stay where they are. They can focus on defence. And their hope, obviously, is that the Entente, that the Allies will wear themselves out and attacking them and eventually will come
是他们取胜的唯一途径。而在另一边，他们固守在法国和比利时的领土上。他们可以待在原地。他们可以专注于防御。显然，他们的希望是协约国——盟军会在进攻他们时耗尽体力，最终会来到
to the negotiating table. But the Germans really do need that to happen quite soon. probably in the next year or so. So just a question, if this had happened, say the French and the British had opened negotiations, if they'd said, look, this is hopeless, we're all going to bleed to death. What terms do you think might have been arrived at?
谈判桌前。但德国人确实需要这种情况尽快发生，大概就在明年左右。所以只是个假设，如果这种情况真的发生了，比如法英两国开启了谈判，如果他们说：“听着，这是无望的，我们都会流血过多而死。”你认为最终可能会达成什么条款？
It's just an impossible question, isn't it? Do you think that to sue for terms would have been a kind of admission of defeat? I think so. If you go to the negotiator's saying, but say, please, can we talk about this? You look weak, don't you? Well, I just, whether you frame it and saying,
这简直是个不可能回答的问题，对吧？你认为求和将是一种战败的承认吗？我想是的。如果你去找谈判代表说：“但是求求你们，我们能谈谈这个吗？”你看上去很弱，不是吗？嗯，我只是在想，无论你如何措辞并说道：
look, we are spilling the blood of young men across Europe. There is no way out of this. You know, it's like a, it's like abandoning a test match where you can't force a victory to use the kind of thing that Lionel Tennyson would have said. But here's the thing, Tom. We mentioned Ukraine earlier on, right? And there's lots of talk right now when we're recording this. People are always saying, should they have a ceasefire? Should they blah, blah, blah. Ukrainians would say the Russians are in possession of quite a bit of our territory. We'll talk to them when we've got rid of them, basically. Why should we just agree to Stop. Well, that's the key question, isn't it? Would the Germans have been willing to withdraw, say, from German-held France? So this is the thing. I think the French would say, we're not prepared to talk to these guys until they get out of our territory. And the Germans would say, well, why would we get out of our territory when this is the one card that we have? So I think it's difficult to imagine how those talks really, I certainly don't think there's going to be Franco-German talks. I mean, again, the British are pretty committed at this point, I think.
“听着，我们正在欧洲各地挥洒年轻人的鲜血。这里没有出路。”你知道的，这就像是——这就像放弃了一场无法迫使自己取胜的板球测试赛，用莱昂内尔·丁尼生会说的那类话。但关键是，汤姆。我们刚才提到了乌克兰，对吧？在我们录制节目的当下，有很多这样的讨论。人们总是在说：他们应该停火吗？他们应该巴拉巴拉巴拉。乌克兰人会说：“俄国人占领了我们相当一部分领土。基本上，等我们把他们赶走后，我们才会和他们谈。”我们凭什么无缘无故同意停火？嗯，这才是关键问题，不是吗？德国人会愿意从德占法国撤军吗？所以问题就在这里。我想法国人会说：“在这些家伙撤出我们的领土之前，我们绝不准备和他们谈。”而德国人会说：“好吧，既然这是我们手里唯一的底牌，我们凭什么撤出领土？”所以我认为很难想象这些谈判究竟会如何进行，我当然不认为会有法德之间的谈判。我的意思是，同样地，英国人在这时也已经陷得很深了，我想。
I've lost a lot of men as well. The problem is, has all that sacrifice been for nothing? How on earth are you going to sell that to your population to say tens, hundreds of thousands of men, but actually we've all made a bit of a mistake. I think that's really hard to imagine. But it would have been the best thing to do. Well, it would have been, and of course later in the war, in particular, there are people who start to make this case, right?
他们也失去了很多士兵。问题是，所有的这些牺牲难道都是白费的吗？你到底要如何向你的民众兜售这种说法——成千上万、数十万的年轻人牺牲了，但实际上我们都犯了一个小错误？我认为这真的很难想象。但这本该是最好的做法。嗯，本该如此，而且当然在战争后期，特别是当有些人开始提出这种观点时，对吧？
There are quite brave people who say, come on, I'm not sure this persisting with this is the right idea. But in 1914, I don't think there's any serious possibility of it happening. The interesting thing, actually, Tom, is that somebody who agrees with you, to some degree, is Eric von Falkenheim. So on the 18th November, basically when the Ieper is lost, he said to the German Chancellor, Betten Holweig, he said, I don't think we can win this on the battlefield. And we start thinking about a political solution. And his, Falconin's idea was that basically you choose one of Russia or France, ideally Russia, and you strike. a separate peace with them. And he said, and I quote, and he's totally right, if Russia, France and England hold together, we cannot defeat them in such a way as to achieve acceptable peace terms. We're more likely to be slowly exhausted. That, of course, is exactly what happens. But Bethven Holbeck says no. And he says no for two reasons. Number one, he says, how on earth would we sell this to the German people? They will never stand for it in a million years. It'd be political. It'd be suicide for the entire governing elite of Germany. And secondly,
有一些非常勇敢的人说：“拜托，我不太确定坚持这样做是不是个好主意。”但在1914年，我认为没有任何发生这种事的现实可能。有趣的是，事实上，汤姆，在某种程度上与你意见一致的人是埃里希·冯·法金汉。所以在11月18日，基本上当伊珀尔战役失利时，他对德国首相贝特曼-霍尔维格说，他说：“我认为我们无法在战场上赢得这场战争。我们应该开始考虑政治解决方案。”而法金汉的想法是，基本上你选择俄国或法国中的一个，最好是俄国，然后对他们发动单独的和谈。他说，我引述他的话——他完全是对的：“如果俄国、法国和英国团结一致，我们就无法以达成可以接受的和谈条款的方式击败他们。我们更有可能会被慢慢耗尽。”这当然正是后来发生的事情。但贝特曼-霍尔维格拒绝了。他拒绝的原因有两个：第一，他说，我们到底该如何向德国人民兜售这一点？他们一百万年也绝不会容忍。这将在政治上成为自杀。对于德国整个统治精英来说，这就是政治自杀。其次，
Beethoven-Holveg is looking to the east because on the eastern front the war has been unfolding very differently. This has been, there's not trenches, it's a story of these huge armies wandering across this huge landscape of grasslands and marshes and the front lines are always changing. So it's a kind of great northern war? It is much more great northern war. And on the eastern front, the Germans have found two new heroes who they think might hold the key to victory.
贝特曼-霍尔维格正将目光投向东方，因为在东线，战争的进展截然不同。这里没有战壕，这是一个关于庞大军队在这片辽阔的草原和沼泽景观中漫游的故事，前线总是在不断变化。所以这有点像一场伟大的北方战争？它确实更像是大北方战争。而在东线，德国人找到了两个他们认为可能掌握胜利钥匙的新英雄。
these people are Paul von Hindenberg and Eric Ludendorf. They are the victors of the Battle of Tannenberg. And to anyone who knows about the rise of the Nazis, they are very, very familiar names. And Tom, we will be telling their story next time. Okay, well, members of the Restis History Club can hear those episodes right now, of course. And if you'd like to join them, if you're not a member of the Restis History Club already, then you can sign up at the Restless History.com. But for now, Beaterseign. Of you see. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这些人就是保罗·冯·兴登堡和埃里希·鲁登道夫。他们是坦能堡战役的胜利者。对于任何了解纳粹崛起历史的人来说，这些都是非常非常熟悉的名字。汤姆，我们下次将讲述他们的故事。好的，那么“不安分的历史”俱乐部成员现在当然就可以收听这些剧集了。如果你想加入他们，如果你还不是“不安分的历史”俱乐部的成员，那么你可以在 TheRestisHistory.com 注册。但现在，再见。再见。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。